[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen there is no reason
we can't talk about the future while
having a little fun
so let me recollect something for you
last year a few of my colleagues and I
were heading to Taiwan the flight as you
know is very long and in the airplane I
was trying to make something work now
that something was a laptop brand-new
laptop the latest it was running Windows
and a little card on which you download
your software you download your
addresses you download your calendar and
then you take the card in your pocket I
had been at it for three hours and my
problem was that when the card software
was happy the operating system wasn't
and vice versa as you well know so we're
in the plane so I turned to one of my
colleagues and I say Tim would you
please help me well Tim berners-lee is a
very gracious man so he said of course
he said I think I can help you so he
picked up the machine an hour and a half
later he hands it back to me still very
polite still very British says I'm sorry
I can't make this name work so I turned
to my friend and associate director Ron
Rivest and I say the inventor of the web
couldn't do it how about you inventor of
RSA and Ron with his characteristic
wisdom looked at me and said no like
thanks and then the youngest member of
our delegation whose name I shall not
mentioned to protect the innocent jumped
up and he says to me
you guys are a bunch of old fogies let
me show you
good LCS attitude
two hours later he hands it to me with
expletives surrounding this I went to my
seat and I did what every expert does I
tried the various wizards and lizards
that were coming up at me and I kept
typing and random things in the fields
until finally three hours later it
worked
total elapsed time nine hours good point
for those who make batteries now ladies
and gentlemen why do I bring this up our
field is young so I don't bring it up to
complain so much this is to be expected
but we are at a junction what I
experienced with that example
is typical of what we have done for the
last 40 years with our field we have
focused on designing for machines we put
little envelopes we call them operating
systems we call them browsers we call
them Network software and then we throw
all this stuff at the user now the image
that this evokes to me is a user you
sitting in your car a car that's very
early vintage and you got rings in every
finger and on every ring is attached to
wire and you got a wire for fuel mixture
you got another wire for advanced of the
ignition you got another one for the
valve clearances the brakes and this and
that and you're sitting there with all
these wires and we say to you go from
Boston to New York ladies and gentlemen
this must stop
40 years is enough
this brings me squarely into my vision
for the 21st century stated in simple
human terms it is simply this people
should be able to do more by doing less
now when I say these simple words which
have been characteristic of every
revolution up to now I mean three things
first we should bring the technologies
of information into our lives now when I
read in the papers and the magazines and
I hear the pundits talk about cyberspace
where we're gonna go this other space
we're gonna leave our lives and go into
submerged cyberspace we're gonna put on
glasses gigabyte in fact it's suits and
we're gonna live an exciting world well
you know when the Industrial Revolution
came we didn't go into motor space
the motors came into our lives we turned
them into refrigerators and we call them
refrigerators not motors we turn them
into cars and call them cars and they
absorbed themselves the motors did into
the functions and tasks that ancient
humans have been doing except now with
new tools so the first thing is bring
the technology into our lives and that's
exactly what I think will happen and
what I wish will happen with the
Information Age they will come into our
lives the new technologies and they will
serve our ancient needs the second thing
that I mean when I say doing more by
doing less is increased human
productivity and increased ease of use
with respect to increased human
productivity first imagine that I'm
holding a handheld
take us to Athens this weekend you'll
see later a system that does this it
took me three seconds to say that the
computer knows that us is two people but
we like to travel business class it
knows the weekend is Friday Saturday
Saturday Sunday it connects with Easy
Sabre it starts doing the exchange as it
tries for Friday it doesn't find an
aisle seat we're like I'll see if it
goes to Saturday finds two seats but
something else is wrong finally books on
Sunday total elapsed time in actual
experiments for this is minimum three
minutes maximum 13 minutes I will take
five minutes as an acceptable average
five minutes is 300 seconds not divided
you went to Harvard for a while that
divided divided by the three seconds the
three hundred seconds gives us a ratio
of 100 productivity leverage but in
business terms that's 10,000 percent we
have achieved a 10,000 percent increase
in human productivity now this is actual
now maybe I do it once a day and you say
it doesn't count but if I was the travel
agent for a large organization it would
count now I don't expect these kind of
gains across the board but I do expect
across the board in the next century and
I explained this in what will be about
300 percent increase in human
productivity primarily in the office
sector today as you look at your
browsers as you look at your email
you're sitting there exercising your
eyeballs and your brains just as hard as
our predecessors exercise their shovels
in the industrial era except you're
using these for your shovels and
shoveling you are
but it isn't painful because the shovels
are stamped high-tech all right let's
take up ease-of-use every time I hear
the word the phrase ease of use from a
vendor of hardware or software I become
physically violent the invariable image
that pops up is of their parading a
chimpanzee around dressed in a green
suit pretending to be a surgeon I mean
the thing isn't easy to use the fact
that they put floating animals and
colors and ergonomics doesn't make it
easy to use what we want is something
that's truly easy to use regardless of
whether it's using graphics or text or
whatever let me pick an example browsers
and operating systems those two worlds
one catering to local information the
computer with this computer system the
other one catering to long distant
information across the browser have
different commands quite different
commands now that doesn't lead to
ease-of-use the image I get from that is
that of an automobile again which when
you're driving it in your neighborhood
local when you turn right it turns right
but when you're driving it on country
roads when you turn the wheel right it
applies the brakes it sounds silly here
but it sounds okay when you highlight an
icon in the operating system and take a
hotlink on the browser with the same
command so we got to revise this kind of
stuff now ladies and gentlemen this is
the second thing that I mean when I say
that we should be able to do more by
doing less the third thing that I mean
is that when we say we we should mean
the people of the world now we feel
pretty smug today because we the people
of the industrially
wealthy world are largely connected but
if you stop and look there are 600
million telephones only which is 10% of
the six billion living on this earth and
in term of these 600 million telephones
only 15% are interconnected about 8090
million people multiply the to 1.5 to 2
percent of the world's population ladies
and gentlemen is interconnected
that's all 98% is disconnected we cannot
hear the millions of voices from the
Indian subcontinent from Africa and from
China although increasingly they're
becoming connected they're all we're
getting is the television feeds and the
government feeds and these people do not
have the opportunity to sell their
services or their products yet on the
world's market through the new medium
now I think it's very important to bring
these people in because left to its own
devices the information revolution will
increase the gap between rich and poor
people the proof is excruciating ly
simple the rich get more computers they
become more productive they get richer
the poor have no computers stay where
they are formula for exponential gap
increase now everybody says we can help
them to get out of the problems etc yes
but we gotta help them alone they cannot
get the machines the communications the
training and the skills to do that it's
important that we do so not only for
Compassion's sake and for altruism but
also for self preservation because
history teaches that when gaps like this
are allowed to grow they result in
bloodshed so ladies and gentlemen
there's so much potential
if we do help the poor not only poor
countries but for people within the rich
countries the kinds of services and
products they could sell the way
they could rise and it's not always
helping from the rich to the poor
imagine a sri lankan doctor a sri lankan
doctor makes $20 a day and speaks
English
imagine that doctor connected through
the world's networks administering
healthcare to homeless people in Boston
could go to a kiosk where there's a
nurse there's a blood cough meter a
monitor they can talk to the doctor
maybe it's not the best health care in
the world because the doctor isn't there
but it's a lot better than no health
care and it might cost two or three
dollars per person at the lab for
computer science a team of
undergraduates is building a virtual
compassion core that I discussed in what
will be this is nothing more nothing
less than a gigantic want ad website
where people who wish to give human help
and people who wish to receive human
help find each other according to the
categories of help and they simply match
with each other and help first time in
our history we could do this worldwide
so to make it short the vision is to let
people do more by doing less and by this
I mean three things first bring the
technology into our lives
second improve human productivity and
ease of use and third include in this
vision all people of the world good
enough for top-level vision but now over
what computing model do we see this
taking place well for the last 20 years
you've heard me talking about the
information marketplace and I'm not
gonna change my tune because we haven't
yet realized it so the model I am
proposing is the same model the
information marketplace which I define
as follows people
and their computers about half a million
to a billion in the next decade plus
appliances gadgets embedded computers
and the like that are unmanned
interconnected together doing three
things by selling and freely exchanging
two things information and information
services now with respect to buying and
selling currently we're at fifty billion
per year on the Internet
my estimate is four trillion in the next
thirty years or so
doing this by going predominantly down
that half of the industrial economy
which is called the office sector
previously quite colorwork half of our
economy is office sector and that is
where the bulk of it will come now a big
part of that is going to be a new kind
of activity we haven't seen yet which I
like to call office information work so
we deal with information as a noun
information as a noun is text sounds
images videos information as a verb is
what a doctor does it's what a thousand
accountants do from Beijing China when
they sell their services to General
Motors in Detroit for $2 an hour
it is the processing the management the
handling of information the service that
is going to be I believe a very large
part of the information marketplace you
add to that the non-dollar component the
family message links the political
discussions the publishing the
administration of health freely where it
happens do-gooder activities chat groups
neighborhoods all that non-dollar huge
component which cannot be measured we
cannot put a four trillion stamp on it
but it's just as important and you have
the picture of this information
marketplace we're not yet there there is
no information work on the current
marketplace there is no automation
there's no capability to do
collaboration all we're doing is we have
a voyeurs exhibitionists have what yours
are browsing the exhibitionist are
saying look at what I'm selling and a
few little transactions between them so
we have a little bit of ways to go
before we get there right so let this be
the vision of doing more by doing less
and let this be the model over which we
will do more by doing less in the
information marketplace now that's still
pretty general so how might we do that
what I would like to do next is to
announce a major research project that
we are launching today at the MIT
laboratory for computer science we call
it oxygen it's a research project it
involves a new radically new system for
tomorrow that contains a lot of this
stuff that I talked about I'm very happy
to say that oxygen went as a proposal
38.5 million dollar proposal to DARPA
and I'm very pleased to say that DARPA
awarded it to us but they haven't
awarded the money yet so we're
negotiating that while I'm at it let me
say you know we always say bad things
about government let me say that in the
last 25 years I've led this laboratory
and the 10 previous years DARPA has been
with us and with other major
universities and they've carved Computer
Science and Technology on the map and
let me say that the current efforts of
the administration to increase the
funding in computer science and the the
various activities that have happened
there are also laudable so we shouldn't
always complain about them they've been
with us and this birthday is largely due
to them all right
oxygen now let me make one more
qualification
before I describe it to you you know
we're not a corporation with a smooth
presentation about a new system we have
a framework now I'm not gonna be
surprised because I'm certain that when
we're done the thing will be totally
different from what I described today as
you hear the talks of my colleagues who
will speak about various pieces of this
keep that in mind and as you hear the
talks of the others who will talk about
other things while pretending to talk
about the pieces keep in mind that this
laboratory does a lot of independent
research keep in mind too that as we do
all these systems work our eyeballs are
focused on trying to understand the
fundamentals and the theories behind
this brave new field of ours without us
background what is oxygen oxygen is
eight technologies which I will now
enumerate and describe very briefly
number one the handy 21 for 21 is for
21st century you see it has a little
display right there
so display which you can see if you're
near-sighted it helps it's like a
cellular phone except that it has in it
a small screen as you've seen it has a
very small analog part the rest is all
digital which means it can change like a
chameleon it's got an infrared detector
and it's got of course a few other odds
and ends which permit it with
downloading to alter its function from a
two-way radio talking to other such
handhelds to a network node talking to
the campus network to a cell phone which
sniffs the air and decides I'm in France
so I'm going to switch to GSM or it says
I'm in America using CDMA and on and on
and on we have done this early prototype
in connection with another DARPA
contract
but victor zue and rock louse key and
clark are involved in and maybe we'll
hear more about it but that is the first
technology of oxygen what we're trying
to do with that is make sure that you
have a thing that is person centric
wherever you go is with you in symmetric
form the second technology of oxygen is
the enviro 21 which is environment
centric it sticks to the wall actually
it's big so it may be in the wall or
under the desk it's in the trunk of your
car it's in your home it is in every
respect like the handy 21 functionally
but it is much bigger so it bears a
relationship of a power socket to a
battery if you wish also the enviro 21
has tentacles which are connected to
sensors and actuators and the famous
appliances we are talking about and it
can control them and also the handy has
a little infrared in it in our current
vision and if you want to bring this
door into your world you put an infrared
tag on the door and when you point the
Handy to it the Machine identity of the
door comes into your system and then you
could bring up a model that says these
are the people working behind it and
this is what they're supposed to be
doing and you could go down the corridor
and check what's behind every door at
least virtually so interesting
possibilities with oxygen the third
technology is n21 Network 21 which is
what we have to add to the internet to
make possible the incorporation of these
highly mobile nodes called people
because the internet goes to fixed
addresses and we want to go to resolve
according to intention it also makes
possible networks that rise and collapse
as people get together for a meeting
makes possible networks of unknown
elements fuzzy networks with self adapt
Asia
and we'll hear more about this later on
these are the three hardware
technologies of oxygen with a lot of
software in them of course the fourth
technology may surprise you because it
is an inner hard core technology it is
built in speech understanding we really
want our machines to be easy to use we
have to make them interact with us
naturally none of us is born with
keyboard sockets or mouse sockets on our
belly we're born with mouths and ears
and that's what we should use dr. Zeus
technologies are fantastic at the narrow
domain level as you heard from Bill
Gates what we are doing now is stitching
together narrow domains to create a
broader listening domain with some human
help so that it can help us navigate
through these various narrow places and
still talk to it the handy 21 has no
keyboard v oxygen technology is
individualized knowledge access by this
I mean that people should be able to
access knowledge in ways familiar to
them and we're talking about low-hanging
fruit here we're not talking about
highfalutin concepts you should be able
to say get me that red book next to the
blue one or next to the document that
came from Paris yesterday and then if
you run out from your own store of goods
and knowledge you go to the store of
your friends and you say assuming they
permit you do you know the answer to
this question can I access this from you
and if that doesn't work you can go out
to the web and get the 5,000 hits but
then in oxygen we triangulate between
those three to try to tailor big hits
with friends and individual knowledge
the sixth oxygen technology is
automation now this is the biggest
workhorse of the information age no
revolution is a true revolution unless
the machines can do our work
take the shovels throw them away bring
in the electronic bulldozers that's what
we want with that technology in oxygen
we offer scripts for you to automate
what you're going to do and you can set
up and control procedures that'll take
place in a given time or when something
arrives you can encapsulate physical
objects deal with them together with
informational objects and create a world
around you that caters to you by off
lighting offloading work from your head
and eyes to the machines
vii oxygen technology is collaboration
and this you can think of as a method of
keeping track of meetings a method of
keeping track of who said what open
issues and a way of zeroing in from
human summaries which may be brief to
fragments of speech that took place in
the meeting all the way to original work
in the meeting that will remind you if
you come back later of what you did the
last the eighth oxygen technology is
customization one of the most variable
resources on the world is human beings
and oxygen enables us to customize to
individual needs besides doing this in
automation and all the other
technologies I mentioned earlier it does
this with all the software in oxygen
there is no shrink-wrap software
everything is downloaded and everything
is adjusted according to whether a user
asks for it or there was an error or
there was a new software made available
this then ladies and gentlemen is oxygen
handed 21s and viral 21s in the wall and
network 21 built-in speech
individualized knowledge access
automation collaboration customization
now these eight are not operating
individually they're operating together
and that's where their power lies and
now I'd like to make a bigger claim when
we envisioned that person with a rings
in his finger trying to drive from
in New York we were wishing that we
could give him gas pedal a steering
wheel and brakes to make it easier to
drive my claim is that the five software
technologies of speech individualized
knowledge access automation
collaboration and customization are
essentially the new kids on the block of
the information age but of the thousands
and millions of things we read that will
be possible a great deal of them can be
done with ease five I believe these are
pretty close to the gas pedal the brakes
and the steering wheel at least for the
next couple of decades or maybe earlier
and if that is true then companies and
individuals will do well to ask in their
companies and in their activities how
can they maximize their own activities
under these five elements imagine a
Health application under oxygen what's
the individualized knowledge access well
it's the doctors records the patient
records its MEDLINE all this has to be
put together triangulated and help the
doctors and then you can imagine the
collaboration when doctors get together
what they will put on that and the
customization for individual doctors and
the automation of routine tasks for
x-rays etc etc so applications will take
their collar from oxygen as applications
have in the past if our dreams come true
now I would like to close ladies and
gentlemen by observing that both my
colleagues and I have been immensely
grateful to work on this the information
revolution for the last many many years
and we're very happy and excited that
we're working on it
right now at this very moment at this
very junction and change the vision of
doing more by doing less on tomorrow's
information marketplace with oxygen as
our first step is where I see us today
and since we're talking about
revolutions I'd like to close with an
observation
and a wish all three revolutions are
based on things the agrarian revolution
was based on the plow the information
revolution which is now happening is
based on the computer and the one in the
middle the Industrial Revolution was
based on the motor
the chemicals so forth well maybe the
time has come for us to start thinking
of a fourth revolution one that is not
based on things but one that tries to
understand the most precious resource on
our planet ourselves thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you